hello hello everyone
oh I'm better oh okay I'm naked right
Wow so should I put on some clothes
probably the most decent thing to do
wouldn't it ah
oh is this my bit I don't have anything
cool on my bit objective get dressed I
think we can do that okay yeah so I'm
taking ages to do things but at least
I'm dressed now I'm decent oh oh hi this
is shower no I'm no okay all my clothes
are wet I need to change your clothes
again
nope okay fine whatever I'll just play
games in wet clothes that's fine
probably can't see any oh yeah that's
nice
okay guys look at the stars with me
isn't this so romantic
okay it's alright we're gonna die soon
he's not gonna say romantic for long
it's very pretty pretty [ __ ] though my
god you're doing good
I'm in this [ __ ] so everyone play
fallout 4 of course you do being in that
suit though I don't like to use it very
much I don't know I don't like feeling
so restricted maybe we should have just
stayed on the other ship
can I die already cuz that's not fair
here we go
I can three I can go invent just like in
the film derp here would have guessed
okay
and do you ever think about if you were
a Pokemon what your little noise would
be you know if you had to make one noise
for the entirety of your life what would
it be what is that noise
it yeah go ended there can be a melt I
was cool someone you always know someone
new you always know working Joe someone
new that you always know working Joe
because that makes sense
not what Pokemon have I always chosen
Felix Charmander
I'm a fire-type everyone's fire aren't
neighbor friends my favorite color
you know fires cool isn't it everyone
went to a little pyromaniac stage what
did I just do I made that little bar go
down well let the music collecting the
compounds all the compounds
I don't know turn it off it's beautiful
are you guys dancing with me can you
guys let me know can you let me know
could you let me make jokes came in
three two one
no Freeman I can't even tell if you know
or if you're just saying it to freak me
out
Oh who's that guys guys guys are
definite guys wait you see me speed out
of that like a follow what are they even
come from they went this way right
no it locks it
I like this game it's really a Miss fair
okay oh I lie I lied to you guys I have
played this before I went to Eurogamer
and played it
they had like a challenge on to see who
could get to the other side the quickest
I think I lasted a few seconds and I
screamed as well and they were behind me
laughing at me the people who are
ah
they escapes thank you wait no no no no
no oh dear
how am I gonna do that
so bring daddy some damage alright how
am I gonna contact them
I would I would what would you do in a
situation like this I wouldn't have the
foggiest I love this game another scam
you know when you go see arcades
I like the shooting games they're my
favorite when you go to arcades
all right the racing car games too
please think something was in here
I think something was trapped in here
and then I just let it out is it just a
mouse I don't know if a mouse could do
that to the light you know whose wishful
thinking I'll give you that I remember
to the alien was one of the first horror
films I stumble across when I got a TV
in my room I was 13 years old stayed up
late watched Channel four or something
and I just saw the bit where they're in
the vent you know and then the alien
thing in the vent and I freaked out
so badly I said the Y turned around that
the way why did I would be horrible or
this in real life okay
what that was so loud in my ear that did
not appreciate that cuz you're gorgeous
what if he just things that alien to
think we can woo it you're like King
Kong did some just camp out here what
did they have a stowaway on board and he
liked dirty mags or she I'm not wait is
that a dirty man no it's not no it's not
as the girls
it's like titty dish the dirt my dad
again choose down huh
okay he's got he's got a skeleton head
do you see it
didn't you see it and then obviously
he's dead what can I come in io n torch
required she started saying that before
she'd even seen him you've already seen
the dead person you didn't react to that
guy game floors okay in the puzzle don't
know where the leak was from my game
clothes
you guys just want me to get to the
alien part don't you're just waiting
you're just excited
I'm just enjoying the scenery the space
I love this is one of the reasons I
bought the PlayStation just because of
that little light oh sweet yeah me too
guys brace yourselves hold it all in
cause it's about to come out alright
guys are you ready are you ready what
would you do right just stop the stream
here anyway that's enough for tonight I
don't why I would never do that to you
okay
okay come on don't you've got bigger
problems to deal with be nicely where'd
you come from
Ripley where'd you come from
rattling ships here there are no well
that's good news
because things are not so good here
something blue just no rock this whole
place
but lady that's the least of our
problems like what you get it okay okay
what's your name max I was boarding with
two colleagues EBA we got separated by
the blast can you help me find them why
to know your way around oh of course
what's in it for me place on the ship my
face if he's in the gym trust you
I need to contact my ship that resting
[ __ ]
well thank you let's go sweetheart
yes an assist expire its give me a
license but we can get to transit
through the freight area let me touch
your bulb hair self you can get an old
sorts of trouble here okay okay wait
what did you say well what are you
waiting for
hit the button you are so bloody
impatient
why can't you hit the button at least
I've got this this man to help protect
me get down composer I didn't move me
Yeah right can I do that I like doing uh
my freaking head why did you do it
what is no trouble you'll have to go
back maybe one my day okay do that my
duck skills friends of yours I've had
run-ins with those guys before they
don't like strangers even nice guys like
me I'm shocked
I tuned your chain behind you want to go
and say hello it's your funeral
those guns sound for sure someone should
be doing something they are its they are
driving
it's called surviving you guys had shoes
your feet it makes people crazy
so sorry to any Scottish people watching
but your accent is cool yeah come on we
don't want to piss him off why I don't
get it guys why do humans always turn
against each other it's like in the
walking dead why can't they just if we
all just trusted each other and worked
against the other force would be fine
okay
gotta be quite here watchin how many
humans are on board this ship it is just
one alien right it's just based on the
first day of the end movie quietly I
have to quiet
oh wait the audio is on Shh I think I've
got to be quiet boy you're probably
prompt me want it do you many of amity
Gordon okay what we do need on we still
got to get through there the door in the
end
Oh
let's try a distraction the generator is
that window they'd have to check it out
by the way bite microphone is wacky I'm
just not saying anything did I what
guys I just died but he was chatting to
me was it because I was loved guys I've
got the audio thing on you know like the
audio thing on the PlayStation game I
think I need to be quiet but I'm gonna
try being quiet present you still got to
get through there
the door at the end can you hear me [ __ ]
they can't hear me
that's what did you see that it's
freaking where I'm gonna turn the audio
thing up no it's detection turn it off
okay the head-tracking stood on OH
both the noise went very loud the noise
went to burnout I think I was in danger
for a second but I'm okay now the audios
off this is gonna be a lot easier for me
now because I can chat that's what I do
i chat i'm ramble that guy's looking at
me but he's not doing anything I think
he's friend look he's still looking at
me he's like huh I forgot see that girl
that I don't know wish you move so I'm
not gonna tell on her I like the way you
move now I can do the audio thing I'm
just I talk too much
okay let's jump through here oh it's
glass no jumping okay
your pokes a guy bra a broken is cute
you don't just do that you can't just go
up poking people and expect to get away
with it well you weren't expecting me to
get away with it why you you you want me
to die Oh balls okay I need to do things
open the vent I just get to yes no one
I'm not yeah no you didn't see nothing
I'm not even here I'm getting out and
getting out it's like in Batman when
they put fire in the vents doesn't suit
me people I'm always in the vent
I'm other an event survey where are you
guys where's Scottish where's Axl oh
there you are
I missed you they're still close by okay
over here okay hey ready on three he
says stand to some hand you bums think
you can take what you want I think
don't you dare my friend where's the
blood that's no blood [ __ ]
let's go the others are on their way we
need to go no sorry
ok come on move it I'm going get intense
I didn't realize that would be I'm so
afraid of humans come on you killed that
guy because he was going to kill me you
saved my sorry I'm on his side this is
about survival
do you understand you have such
beautiful eyes
okay guys that's it from the stream
thanks for watching I have a feeling
that was not the wisest of ideas I'm
scared
why is where is
I'm supposed to be doing clean comes to
see arts for this can I just stay in
this corner that's good
that's fine we're good well good
everything's fine hey hey hey friends
I'm too naive I know everybody not [ __ ]
do I do
she knows I'm here now I believe my car
bugs I'm too naive I just want a friend
I don't like being alone
oh my god
I'm an idiot I'm so needy cool
don't trust the synthetics I want to get
that she's scaring me she's spitting
holder hey can you see me
am i hidden oh I'm hidden good oh my god
this is scary don't look don't turn
around did I get that from all the way
over there I did
Wow I have I have no density with
nothing no you didn't you didn't see me
I need to find a place to hide Oh God he
is following me he is following me I'm
not going down there no way she's got
your hack tool it didn't work we'll find
another way up we've been here too long
already it didn't work
oh wait Joyce is with noises oh okay
what do you want okay out of all these
guys which one would you which would you
choose
Pizza a mega burger a mega burger
whatever that is a mega burger french
fries hamburgers chicken nuggets hot dog
veggie wrap fried chicken or a horse
burger get me pizza Thanks where's key
cap
oh well I got a gun that's helpful sure
but there's still no key card someone
said it was in the air but oh my god
whoever said it was in here you are
genius thank you thank you thank you I
owe you the progression of this live
stream
mmm-hmm that's lovely let's go check out
this guy oh god yeah I can't imagine
these smiles too good Oh such shotgun
shells yes please give me the shotgun
where's the shotgun I don't like those
noises
wait what flames right I do get oh yes I
do get flank
so I guess that was the way that she was
gonna get in touch with the other
fellowship can I save the game please
okay I'll go you I need to UM I need to
use a bloody health bag med kit I don't
know the controls
ah okay ah Chris oh my god Christmas
fever cared for the scares
oh and you ready to sing to it
did you guys ever play the alien vs.
predator game will you actually got to
be the alien I I think I prefer pit in
the predator though aliens caller a
perfect organism
okay that was the trophy understand
well at least I don't have to worry
about those guys anymore
plus we're shite
that's so okay and all of this glory I
don't want to go down there that's what
he is
oh [ __ ] coming up here okay let's get up
let's search these guys I'm gonna set
I'm gonna try running in buddies and I'm
going through the door
that's one oh what fun
oh why is this are they thank you hack
the elevator
dude there what why did I say like that
ah today I don't feel like I've been
scared enough yet what do you guys think
I've been quite brave hey guy hey friend
Hey hello my name um Amanda Ripley I
need your help please take a seat
someone will be with you shortly
I don't think they well they no wonder
seek citizen is in the tech race another
robot she think they'll be friendly I
need to get into comms control it's
urgent it's an emergency
don't you realize what's going on Obama
has the situation in hand your
registration is almost complete forget
it I'll find my own way in could your
face I'm not gonna take orders from a
robot I am a robot
I think of comments at the end of this
dream some kind of tracker Oh
it's been modified I know this tracker
oh hello
Nogueira no problem
cuz this is a nice music I miss the
just take a second smell things listen
to me
we've got to reestablish long-range
communications you're becoming
hysterical get back I'm warning you
don't cross the sense
I want that gun okay then yeah thought I
thought at least the robots are nice it
looks like I was wrong I'm sorry man I
could have helped you but instead I just
stayed hidden in the vent but to be fair
you would have probably killed me anyway
with you
oh wait where's the gun what ah whatever
where did that evil sense go is that the
evil one that's what I was talking to
you just now he's not the same one is he
what's that noise idea
Hey so question can I trust you
Hey oh god no maybe not maybe not Oh
eggs okay it's cool that's not like nice
cheese my gun on you
you're bleeding
oh god there's loads of them okay let's
just run this is run where am I going
I don't know summer
all right in the Benz yo they don't
follow me in here do them aha mmm should
we go and kill them or will I regret
that decision
aim for the head how many shots does it
take whatever what I got you in the
freakin air there's no need for this but
there is them oh gosh oh wait what's the
door
okay don't attract me on the bed please
thank you let's just get through the
camera bit baby yeah
and progress thank you guys it has come
to the end I'm gonna save the game and
then that it's gonna be it for tonight
I'm pretty sure we've been streaming for
longer than three hours
that is a while thank you so so much for
watching this live stream it's always
such a pleasure to play with you guys
and I'm not even exaggerating you're
amazing I love being part of this
wonderful community and I will not ever
stop saying it to you guys because it's
just it's true okay it's just true you
make me happy